in our clinical trials.
STEVE: TENNESSEE LAWMAKERS
SOUNDING THE ALARM AFTER REPORTS
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
SECRETLY FLYING UNACCOMPANIED
MIGRANT KIDS INTO TENNESSEE IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT WITHOUT
TELLING THE LOCAL AUTHORITIES.
REPUBLICAN TENNESSEE CONGRESSMAN
MARK GREEN WANTS ANSWERS FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE AND HE JOINS US
NOW FROM NASHVILLE.
CONGRESSMAN, GOOD MORNING.
>> HEY, STEVE, THANKS FOR HAVING
ME ON.
STEVE: THERE IS A STORY THAT
THEY ARE FLYING THESE KIDS INTO
AIRPORTS LIKE CHATTANOOGA,
UNANNOUNCED THEY DIDN’T NOTIFY
LOCAL AUTHORITIES.
WHY WOULD THAT BE?
WHY WOULDN’T THEY GIVE YOU A
GUYS A HEADS UP HEY WE ARE DOING
THE MIGRANT PROCESS.
WE ARE GOING TO BRING THEM INTO
TENNESSEE?
WHY WOULDN’T THEY TELL YOU?
>> WELL, FIRST, STEVE, YOU KNOW,
HOW DO WE GET HERE?
WE GOT HERE BECAUSE JOE BIDEN
DID AWAY WITH THE ASYLUM
AGREEMENTS AND THE DRUG CARTELS
ARE GRABBING THESE CHILDREN,
COMING ACROSS CENTRAL AMERICA,
DUMPING THEM AT OUR BORDER AND
GETTING INTO OUR COUNTRY.
BASICALLY BIDEN’S FACILITATING
HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
AND THEN THEY GOT TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT TO DO.
SO, THEY CALL -- I SPOKE TO OUR
GOVERNOR LAST NIGHT ABOUT THIS
ISSUE.
HE HAS DONE A VERY GOOD JOB
KEEPING US INFORMED.
HE WAS CALLED TWO WEEKS AGO BY
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION AND
ASKED DO YOU WANT TO TAKE, YOU
KNOW, THESE MIGRANTS, THESE
MIGRATION HE SAID NO WE DO NOT
WANT TO TAKE THEM.
THAT’S WHY THEY ARE HAVING TO
SNEAK THEM INTO TENNESSEE WE
TOLD THEM YOU CAN’T JUST BRING
THEM HERE WITHOUT OUR PERMISSION
AND THEY ARE DOING IT ANYWAY.
STEVE: YOU KNOW, ABOUT A MONTH
OR SO AGO, KIM REYNOLDS THE
GOVERNOR OF IOWA WAS ASKED CAN
WE BRING KIDS TO IOWA?
SHE SAID NO.
WE DON’T KNOW IF THEY ARE FLYING
THEM INTO WATERLOO UNDER THE
COVER OF DARKNESS BUT WE DO KNOW
THAT IS HAPPENING IN TENNESSEE.
YOU WOULD THINK THAT THE
GOVERNMENT WOULD ASK THE STATE
FOR PERMISSION AND THEY WOULD
HAVE TO BE GRANTED IT BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT, YOU KNOW, THOUSANDS
OF MIGRANTS ON YOUR DOORSTEP
COULD BE A HUGE FINANCIAL, YOU
KNOW, COULD SUCK A LOT OF MONEY
OUT OF YOUR STATE COFFERS.
>> SURE.
ABSOLUTELY IT’S AN UNFUNDED
MANDATE.
YOU THINK ABOUT IT I WAS A STATE
SENATOR.
AND WE LOOKED AT THE COST OF THE
REFUGEE PROGRAM YEARS AGO
ENGLISH AS A SECOND LANGUAGE AND
STATE HAVE TO PAY FOR THAT
EDUCATION SYSTEM.
YOU CAN GIVE THEM TO NONPROFITS
WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY WHAT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS NOW
DOING.
THE TAXPAYER WINDS UP PAYING
THIS BILL.
AND THEY ARE
BASICALLY ---BASICALLY UNFUNDED
MANDATE BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
IT FITS COMPLETELY THOUGH WITH
THE JOE BIDEN LEFTIST MENTALITY
THAT ALL POWER SHOULD RESIDE IN
WASHINGTON, D.C. AND THEY CAN
JUST IGNORE THAT TENTH AMENDMENT
AND FORCE TENNESSEE TO DO THIS.
STEVE: WE HAVE STATEMENT FROM
HHS BUT DO NOT ADDRESS WHY THEY
ARE FLYING KIDS INTO TENNESSEE.
AS PART OF THE IT PROCESS
FACILITATING TRAVEL FOR THE
CHILDREN IN CUSTODY TO THEIR
SPONSORS TO PREVENT ANY DELAYS.
CONTRACTORS USE VARIOUS
TRANSPORTATION MODES TO GET THEM
WHERE THEY ARE GOING.
THAT DOESN’T SAY WHY THEY ARE
NOT TELLING YOU GUYS.
IF HE LOOKS LIGHTER IT’S BECAUSE
HE IS $500 LIGHTER.
YOU GOT A FINE FOR NOT WEARING A
MASK ON THE HOUSE FLOOR BECAUSE
NANCY PELOSI UNLIKE THE SENATE,
WHERE YOU DON’T HAVE TO WEAR A
MASK, SHE SAYS YOU’VE GOT TO
WEAR A MASK.
ALTHOUGH WE SAW HER YESTERDAY, I
BELIEVE IT WAS AT THE WHITE
HOUSE AND SHE STUNT HAVE A MASK
THERE.
WHAT IS SHE TRYING TO PROVE.
RUB THE NOSES IN THIS.
ALL THE DEMOCRATS ARE VACCINATED
AND NOT ALL THE REPUBLICANS ARE.
>> YEAH.
STEVE, THIS IS THE DEFINITION OF
HYPOCRISY.
YOU KNOW, LEADERSHIP 101 AT WEST
POINT FOR ME.
35 YEARS AGO.
THE FIRST THING THEY TEACH YOU
IS YOU NEVER ASK PEOPLE TO DO
SOMETHING YOU, AS THE LEADER,
AREN’T WILL TO DO.
HERE SHE IS IN THE HOUSE AT THE
SPEAKER’S ROSS STRUM NOT WEARING
A MASK.
SHE GOES TO THE WHITE HOUSE NOT
WEARING A MASK SHE IS KEEPING
THIS VERY UNSCIENTIFIC.
WE ALL KNOW IF YOU ARE
VACCINATED THE CDC CAME OUT WITH
THIS.
YOU DON’T HAVE TO WEAR A MASK.
THEY ARE FORCING IT.
EVEN IN COMMITTEE, SHE BASICALLY
COMPELLED THE HOUSE PHYSICIAN TO
CHANGE HIS RULE.
HIS KNEE JERK RESPONSE TO THE
CDC WAS HEY, LET’S NOT WEAR MASK
IN COMMITTEE.
SHE CAME BACK, HE HAD TO RETRACT
THAT AND CHANGE IT.
IT’S JUST HARASSMENT, BASICALLY.
STEVE: SO YOU ARE SAYING SHE
PRESSURED THE ATTENDING
PHYSICIAN TO CHANGE THE RULES.
>> I CAN’T IMAGINE WHY A
PHYSICIAN WOULD COME OUT WITH
ONE RULE.
THERE WERE NO STUDIES IN THE
ENSUING FOUR DAYS.
I’M SPECULATING WHY HE AS A
PHYSICIAN WOULD CHANGE HIS
CLINICAL GUIDANCE.
STEVE: DON’T GET NOT WEARING A
MASK AGAIN OR IT’S 2500 BUCKS
OUT OF YOUR POSSIBILITY.